boa tarde hoje eu vim compartilhar com
vocês uma idéia ea idéia central de que
o verdadeiro ato revolucionário a educar
para a alteridade
essa parece ser uma afirmativa simples
mas não é absolutamente simplória como
nós podemos imaginar
e pra isso a gente vai conversar um
pouco sobre alguns exemplos bastante
contemporânea
talvez um dos maiores problemas da
contemporaneidade seja o problema do
fluxo migratório
nós temos hoje um fluxo migratório que
ultrapassa os 7 8 milhões de pessoas
refugiados de guerras e conflitos
internacionais de problemas étnicos em
vários lugares do mundo é e um exemplo
que eu trouxe para nós conversarmos é
sem dúvidas o exemplo das grandes nações
européias que têm é assolado boa parte
do mundo a alemanha recebeu nos últimos
tempos no seu sistema educacional 250
mil refugiados
naturalmente nenhuma nação do mundo está
preparado para lidar com que nós
chamamos efetivamente estrangeiro
o estrangeiro demanda de todos nós um
exercício contínuo sobre a alteridade
não há dúvida de que o problema
migratório encontra se presente em toda
a humanidade desde países como a
jordânia que não tem água para lidar com
todos os imigrantes que recebe até um
país que tem um alto grau de
desenvolvimento tecnológico e econômico
como a alemanha
para vocês terem uma idéia esses 250 mil
novos estudantes nas escolas alemãs que
não falam a língua alemã demandaria 20
mil novos professores nem as
universidades alemães teriam condição
nesse exato momento de formar
professores suficiente para dar conta
dessa quantidade de novos estudantes com
idiomas completamente diferente numa
sala de aula comum na alemanha hoje é
capaz de nós termos sete países
diferentes dentro da mesma sala com até
14 idiomas diferentes
você imagina o que é educar né num
sistema onde a língua já não é mais
possível é de ser o principal elemento
constante
toda a educação todos nós estamos
acostumados a pensar que a primeira
forma o primeiro ato de educar é o
reconhecimento da linguagem
se nós não reconhecemos pela linguagem
teremos uma grande dificuldade é nesse
sentido então essa questão tem
demandados das professores alemães do
estado alemão uma grande necessidade de
repensar o que é a alteridade e pra isso
a gente vai ter que conversar sobre por
que a verdadeira revolução é o ato de
educação pela austeridade é uma pesquisa
encomendada pelo parlamento alemão
mostra pra nós que do ano passado para
cá mais de mil e 400 casos ocorreram de
antissemitismo na alemanha e provam que
a palavra judeu voltou a ser um
xingamento nas escolas alemãs
mesmo naquelas escolas onde não há
nenhum judeu e mesmo naquelas escolas
onde não há nenhum imigrante
essa é uma questão chave é uma questão
central da contemporaneidade
nós precisamos educar para a alteridade
autoridade ao reconhecimento total do
outro
especificamente quando nós não
acreditamos mais do outro quando
deixamos de pensar que o outro pode nos
reconhecer
deixamos de nos responsabilizar pelo
outro eu vou contar um exemplo pra vocês
que ocorreu em 1943 é no território
ocupado pela alemanha mais precisamente
no lugar
a polônia na cracóvia chamado auschwitz
eu tive a oportunidade em 2014 de
entrevistar um sobrevivente por volta de
92 anos mais ou menos que tinha passado
pelo campo de extermínio de auschwitz um
ele veio de salônica na grécia família
inteira dele foi assassinada no treino
comboio que saía de salônica até
auschwitz era o maior trajeto dos campos
de extermínio durava oito dias dentro do
trem ele encontrou uma antiga paquera
uma moça jovem muito bonita e agrava na
adolescência no colégio e eles fizeram
um pacto naquele trem e esse pacto foi
que se eles saíssem vivos eles iriam se
casar se eles voltassem a se encontrar
hoje daquele trem eles iriam de fato é é
conceder o matrimônio iriam formar uma
família
eles se separaram durante a guerra ela
vai pra lá o campo feminino ele fica é
em auschwitz um e ela vai para o
processo de esterilização feita pelo
médico alemão e usa miguel era uma
característica desse campo de extermínio
em específico
no dia em que os médicos acórdão levam
ela de manhã para a sala de
esterilização é acontece soou o alarme
de bomba de ataque a auschwitz ea
esterilização é cancelada
havia uma tradição é da equipe médica de
auschwitz que todas as vezes que a
esterilização era feita algum médico
judeu deveria participar
essa talvez tenha sido uma das maiores é
dos maiores complicadores em relação à
autoridade do próprio fascismo ele fez a
vítima ser algoz dela mesmo né e essa
questão é a negação total do princípio
de educação e de reconhecimento do outro
então no dia seguinte esse médico judeu
que iria participar da esterilização
dela acorda mais cedo a pega pelo braço
ea leva na maca para o centro cirúrgico
e faz a esterilização sem nenhum outro
médico nazista por perto quando miguel
passa no pavilhão ela já estava
esterilizada
o tempo passa a guerra acaba ela
sobrevive ele também sobrevive e no
campo de refugiados eles se encontram
quando eles se encontram enfim decidem
se casar se casar ainda no campo de
refugiados e fazem a migração para o
estado de israel quando chegam em israel
vão morar na galiléia e decidem criar um
kibutz e com muita pobreza naquele
momento em 1948 o kibutz que eles criam
não tem banheiro eles tinham que sempre
há um banheiro de uma casa vizinha para
poder fazer as necessidades de tomar
banho etc para e ela chega para ele e
diz meu amor eu não vou mais aquele que
boots não vou mais aquele banheiro eles
porque porque toda vez que eu volto de
lá minha barriga dói muito
que coisa estranha ela está indo ao
banheiro porque a barriga tá doendo toda
vez que volta e com o passar do tempo
ela descobre que está grávida
e aí começa o grande problema como ela
pode estar grávida
se ela foi esterilizada em 1943 por um
médico e ela recorda dizendo que na hora
da esterilização antes de começar o
procedimento ela olha pra ele diz você
também é judeu porque você está fazendo
isso eu amaldiçoou até a tua última
geração por você tirar de minha condição
de ser mãe e ele calado continua o
procedimento
depois ela descobre quando já atenta
para que está grávida de que ele não
tinha feito a esterilização ele tinha
aberto mas não tinha feito absolutamente
nada e que o médico tinha sido
assassinado dez dias depois porque ele
fez o mesmo procedimento em 300 mulheres
e se a questão fundamental que nós temos
atentar para quando pensamos de que
reconhecer o outro não é só a aceitá lo
s responsável por ele e esse é o
princípio revolucionário da educação
se nós não somos capazes de nos tornar
responsáveis pelo outro não adianta
apenas reconheceu o simples
reconhecimento nos torna capaz de ser
responsáveis a ponto de sentir a dor do
outro capaz de arriscar a nossa própria
vida por ele como foi o caso desse
médico e o mesmo ocorre hoje quando você
coloca 250 mil crianças numa escola que
fala um idioma que menos de 250 milhões
de pessoas no mundo fala o grande
problema dessas crianças não está
especificamente em aprender alemão
elas aprendem até com uma certa
facilidade e até falam muito raro muito
bem rápido a necessidade faz com que
elas aprendam isso o grande problema
está em elas se sentirem reconhecidas e
aceitas em uma cultura extremamente
diferenciada
vejam que os alemães têm feito nesse
exato momento é com uma educação de base
majoritariamente tecnicismo a educação
alemã está dividida em três grandes
escolas é primeiro a chamado chamado
ginásio alemão
depois o real chula e depois o rap de
chula são três tipos de escola as
crianças na alemanha são separadas
aos 11 anos de idade por aí
te dão notas aos 11 anos você já sabe
quem vai frequentar a universidade quem
não vai frequentar a universidade
essa é uma tarefa duríssima você imagina
aos 11 anos dizer àqueles que são
capazes de ir ao ensino superior e
aqueles que não são que vão ser
divididos em dois tipos de ensino
técnico
o ensino técnico formal comum de uma
profissão técnica e um ensino técnico é
financiado por empresas que vão guiar a
sua é a sua vida que vão modificar se
você está indo bem na escola se você
está cumprindo o papel etc e etc
aos 11 anos as crianças que estão no
ensino técnico e os adolescentes que vão
para o ensino técnico eles podem optar
depois no futuro de voltar para o ensino
universitário mas não tem que estudar
cinco anos a mais por isso
numa sociedade onde o tempo é
fundamental numa sociedade onde o tempo
rege a vida das pessoas
os ingleses até podem ter inventado
relógio mas quem botou pilha foram os
alemães nenhuma sociedade gosta tanto do
tempo
nenhuma sociedade respeita tanto tempo
como os alemães fazer na sua juventude
literalmente não ter acesso ao ensino
superior por escolhas tão pequenas
é uma questão que diz respeito ao tempo
fundamental é uma contradição um grande
paradoxo esse modelo educacional alemão
é sempre valorizado pelo mundo inteiro
porque diminuir largamente a evasão é o
país da união europeia membros da união
europeia com o terceiro menor índice de
evasão escolar chega a menos de 11% é
isso seria uma grande verdade isso seria
possível de ser feito num país como o
nosso está provado que o próprio vizinho
da alemanha à polônia que tem um sistema
universal onde as crianças só são
separadas aos 16 anos é tem o índice de
evasão escolar que chega à metade do da
alemanha isso significa que esse modelo
educacional é uma cultura política de
uma determinada sociedade serve para os
alemães mas possivelmente não serve para
todo mundo
uma outra questão fundamental que nós
temos que ter clareza quando falamos
plenamente da idéia de educação para
alteridade é que nós não precisa
vamos é fazer esse estrangeiro se sentir
culpado por ser estrangeiro e quando eu
falo estrangeiro eu não estou falando
para vocês que o estrangeiro é
simplesmente um haitiano o boliviano um
paraguaio que veio estudar numa escola
pública brasileira
eu falo que o estrangeiro está todo dia
na sala de aula quando nós encontramos
ao que é diferente daquilo que nós
chamamos de comum de padrão
um exemplo também houve volta uma escola
alemã em 1938 quando uma pequena menina
por volta de 10 anos de idade que
freqüentavam uma escola comum geral na
alemanha antes da proibição de judeus
frequentarem escolas na alemanha e ela
chega em casa chorando muito
rasga a estrela de davi que tornou se
obrigatória por conta do estado fascista
alemão e diz à mãe que tem um grande
ódio na vida o óleo de ter nascido judia
e essa é uma questão fundamental para
nós aquele que perpetra o ódio é capaz
de fazer o estrangeiro esse caso essa
garota judia na escola não sentir raiva
do agressor
ela sente raiva da sua condição ela
sente raiva de ser o que é
desistir da forma que é esse talvez seja
o maior ato contraditório da alteridade
fazer a vítima se transformar em uma
vítima dela mesmo
especificamente ela não consegue
produzir raiva daquele que emite o ódio
mas ela passa a sentir raiva da condição
que ela possui desistir por isso é
fundamental que o ato de educação não
seja somente um ato de reconhecimento
mas seja acima de tudo um ato de
responsabilização quando o outro sócio
preconceito quando o outro sofre a dor a
dor precisa ser universal o que faz com
que o mundo continue tendo grandes
problemas em relação à alteridade e que
esses problemas sejam eterno passado que
não passa é efetivamente a nossa
incapacidade de reconhecer o outro
se nós não fizermos isso seremos
incapazes de revolucionar o mundo ea
educação é por excelência um projeto
coletivo
esse é um projeto coletivo ela só se dá
no exercício da ua
ter idade não é possível fazer de outra
forma e para isso eu trouxe pra vocês
uma coisa que me chamou muito a atenção
há dois meses atrás do estado de são
paulo numa livraria e deixe de comprar
novamente um autor brasileiro que eu
gosto demais chamado guimarães rosa e
guimarães rosa todo mundo fala ele
escreveu coisas lindas maravilhosas de
um português próprio difícil ea gente
tem duas línguas portuguesas a
tradicional e inventada por guimarães
rosa e ele escreveu um livro chamado
manuelzão e miguilim um livro muito
significativo sobre a história de um
menino chamado mirim que num determinado
aspecto da vida da infância recebe um
par de óculos e esse par de óculos muda
completamente a vida de miley porque faz
com que ele perca completamente a
inocência de ver o mundo como ele via
quando era é quando era criança e quando
via o mundo com essa ingenuidade da
mesma forma que aquela mulher lá de
salônica na grécia não foi capaz de
olhar para aquele que era igual ao seu e
dizer naquele momento você é o fascista
naquele momento você estava
esterilizando eu te odeio por isso
naquele momento ela tirou a ingenuidade
de acreditar nas pessoas
ela perdeu a fé elas o mesmo ocorre com
essa criança do conto de guimarães rosa
nós precisamos efetivamente daquilo que
me limpem quando não ainda possui um par
de óculos a inocência a forma de ver o
mundo com uma certa ingenuidade
ao mesmo tempo ele possui um irmão que
pra ele se posiciona como um alter ego
dito que consegue ser a grande
maturidade aquele que consegue de fato
dizer a ele as coisas que ele não queria
te ouvir é ele sempre disse eu não quero
crescer eu quero continuar sendo criança
adulto falam coisas muito duras e tem
ações muito dolorosas e perversas
eu quero continuar sendo ingênuo como
uma criança e eles estão de mudança de
uma cidade do interior de minas pra
outra ea mãe dele está na janela da
porta da casa e olha visto uma montanha
e fala e
não gosto dessa montanha eu não consigo
saber o que tem atrás dela
o que está atrás dela esconde de 1.000
mundo que eu não sou capaz de ver que eu
não consigo ver
e essa metáfora usada por guimarães rosa
é muito praticada quando eu falo a
questão da discussão da alteridade dia a
dia que nós temos que tratar a questão
da alteridade do reconhecimento e do
respeito para com o outro como alvo de
uma luta diária não adianta você ficar
na janela olhando a montanha e dizendo
que o que está atrás dela está escondido
porque efetivamente ela pode até lá e se
chegar até lá ela pode conseguir
descobrir o que tem atrás
o grande problema é que para chegar até
lá você vai ter que passar por um
caminho usando as palavras de guimarães
rosa de veredas um caminho duro um
caminho difícil não é fácil o
reconhecimento do outro não é uma tarefa
simples porque demanda em primeiro lugar
você tirar de você
o egoísmo que que é presente em todo o
mundo demanda você se despedir
preconceitos demanda você reconhecer que
o outro nunca será aquilo que você e ele
só pode ser aquilo que ele quer se
demanda você tentar não normatizar o
outro como vida não normatizar o outro
como sujeito não fazer com que o mundo
seja sua vontade de representação esse é
o grande problema
nós não nascemos nós amássemos
enxergando mundo nós aprendemos enxergar
o mundo mas somos ensinados a enxergar
tem um determinado contrato antigo que
dizia que um homem que não tinha visão e
que recorda a visão depois de um
determinado tempo toda vez que ele
tocava o objeto ele primeiro fechava os
olhos ele fechava os olhos tocava disse
então enfim isso é um lápis isso é uma
caneta ele preferia primeiro fechar os
olhos para mesmo enxergando depois
reconhecer isso é a frase clássica de
que nós não nascemos aprendendo a já
nascemos sabendo mundo nós somos
ensinados efetivamente é a ler e ler o
mundo significa nesse exato momento
voltar à condição
mana de ler os indivíduos ou nós
voltamos de uma educação para a
autoridade
voltamos fadados a conviver com o
fascismo que é a negação a diferença se
nós quisermos efetivamente educar e
revolucionar
precisamos reconhecer o outro
[Aplausos]